hey Chauncey Heep Chauncey first of all
what's up and secondly he says dr. Tyson
Moon or Mars oh I mean I love that
because the whole question is implicit
in those two hey you guys where you want
to go first there you go the marginal go
to moon go to Mars with it's harder and
do you have the money can you do it yet
can we do the moon first and you can do
that in a new cycle because it only
takes three days to go to the moon you
hang out come back you're back in a week
Mars is years so I'm saying I'm a
contrarian here country I have I'm
driving in a different Lane okay my Lane
is we should turn the whole solar system
into our backyard with a lineup of
booster rockets and take two from here
three from there that gets you to Mars
right one from there two from there that
gets you to an asteroid right what we
should not be thinking of destinations
we should be thinking of capabilities
Wow
and if you think of capabilities as a
goal in the entire solar system becomes
your backyard and nothing sits out of
reach
hot damn that was good ha ha ha mic drop
Indra hey did you like that cool video
huh well how about a bunch of cool
videos all commercial three plus
exclusive original content that you
can't find anyplace else all on Startalk
all-access calm